de beaux garçons pour terminer à
l'occasion du salon du prêt-à-porter qui
s'ouvre à la porte de versailles à paris
ça change parce que d'habitude les
hommes se font plaisir en montrant des
mannequins féminins
bref avec dominique b you et embrasse
paiera nous allons savoir maintenant
comment nous allons les croquer au
printemps prochain quand la mode et
exhibitions elle est signée angelo tard
l'asie
le styliste italien qui a repris la
succession de guy laroche pour les
femmes produits sous son nom une
collection homme ou le sous vêtement est
hissé à la hauteur du vêtement si les
petits marcel et autres maillots sont à
l'honneur il faut remarquer aussi que le
béret franchouillard est enfin
réhabilité mais il est sérieusement
concurrencé par le bon vieux bob dans la
mode et enchantement elle est due à
montana une mention spéciale pour ses
tenues sable décliné de mille et une
façons saharienne sur amples pantalons à
pinces posthume me réhausser le clou
vestes fermées par des petits noeuds
ou encore trois pièces est classique
avec l'inévitable gillet beau travail de
recherche sur l'école aussi bien pour
les baisses que pour les chemises audace
dans les assemblages de couleurs montana
est vraiment un grand
quand la mode des caricatures c'est
thierry mugler qui s'amusent ligne il
fait remarquer pour des tenues coupé à
la serpe retour du col anglais pour
séducteur nordique beaucoup de rayures
ici on ne fait pas vraiment dans la
discrétion
si jack lang reste fidèle à son
couturier fétiche
on peut lui prédire beaucoup de succès
enfin quand la mode des grands digne au
losc c'est bien sûr jean paul gaultier
qui est derrière c'est le show pour le
show pour le reste cela en est sera
froid plus d'un mais des goûts et des
couleurs on ne discute pas ce qui est
certain c'est que ce n'est pas pour rien
que jean paul gaultier organise ses
défilés au cirque d'hiver